- But I have to ask this 'cause
I remembered hearing this
and I was like, I gotta
ask her an interview.
Is it sure that Jennifer
Aniston would come over
to play at your house as
a little girl in the 70s?
- As a teenager, I mean
as like a middle teenager
and eat me outta house and home and
(audience laughing)
(Kelly laughing)
it's like the kids, the
girls always used to,
you know they knew when
I would went to Balducci
and they would just show
up and just chow down
and she was a big chow downer.
(audience laughing)
- I love it.
I didn't know.
I just think that's so funny,
nobody knows that behind the
scenes of like how people
that you don't know are
related in some way,
in some capacity, like back in the day.
That's so cool to me.
Did you know, did anybody
know that she was acting
and gonna do anything
like that at that age?
'Cause she was so young?
- Well, no, I mean, she was
going to school, you know
she was going to High
School of Performing Arts.
And this is one thing that I know,
it's like when my mom used
to say to anybody she met,
I have a daughter who sings.
Well the minute you say that,
people just turn it off.
And she, and Ahmet Ertegun
the big manager and owner
of Atlantic Records,
my mom said, I have a daughter who sings.
And he said, yes, Georgia, that's good.
And then he signed us
and then we're singing.
And one night my mom comes in and he said,
Georgia, what are you doing here?
And she said, I told you I
have a daughter that sings.
There she is.
(audience laughing)